hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to chicken walk an actual
chicken simulator which is kind of
strange to me but hey I've had a long
day recording with Bob and wait for more
D mod stuff and a few extra surprises
that I know that you're gonna love but
for now I think I'll kick back and relax
from all the horror oculus rift games
that I've been doing and just be it
freakin chicken I guess that's really
all there is to it I don't know who why
for what reason but here I am oh my
goodness oh good god I think I have
those chicken testicles hanging out my
beak that's right here and very
disorienting for me anyway so I got
nothing to say about this game hello oh
hello babies oh my god you are you wanna
touch beaks boink boink that is
exceptionally close to me but hello
babies
I got a carrion be my chicken thing if
you know what I mean
Oh little baby you are just the most
adorable thing I've ever seen in my
entire life
you were absolutely adorable okay Bank
okay Bank to score I got a time limit
food and water meter and health bars
kind of like Legend of Zelda health bars
water that yeah that did it okay got
water and so so what about that wait a
minute was that hang on I see something
over here was it there's a seed we need
that food yeah that did it oh this moral
here it's just like hit me the
ridiculousness of what I am doing I am
literally pretending to be a chicken
this is how far what the hell okay this
is literally how far gaming technology
has come I have what looks to be an egg
in the top left corner of my screen so
I'm guessing that's important or
something
let me that time quickly I I need to
find more of those time things it said
left
I should be sprinting I don't know why
I'm not spreading whoa whoa whoa what
happened whoa it got dark did I get
freaky with a chicken I think I go whoa
hi
oh no what what happened oh no you're
off Fox oh no no no no my baby no my
baby no not my baby don't get my baby oh
hi oh god oh I am flying I'm a chicken
and I am finally flying this is so weird
this looks amazing by the way I don't
think I mentioned that this is oh submit
score it's too busy looking down at the
ground oh yeah hey Oh God our okay offer
forget it
good all my goodness that is a very
strong rainbow I didn't even make the
scoreboard I want to play again Han I
got a press are to restart okay so I got
to play that again holy hell that was
awesome and I made a little baby okay so
I got a sprint from the start cuz
otherwise I'm not gonna have enough time
I don't think so I got a sprint I don't
need to do anything here uh get some
water I'm guessing that the food and
water will go quickly when I'm sprinting
but I don't have enough time to waste I
need to get as many of those good god I
can't believe I'm taking this game so
seriously this is absolutely bonkers we
know I didn't what can I get through the
fence new cannot can't break the rules
of this game
oh my god it's so I want too hot I want
to score high oh there's another one of
those Fox bastard OOP oh you didn't see
nothing you didn't see nothing I need to
get to my baby I don't have a baby yet
but I'm gonna have one soon oh my god
this is scarier than any horror game
I've ever played yeah you run away you
run away you little goober see there
I've almost got enough for another egg
where's another one I mean another ah oh
you didn't see nothing keep bending are
bending abandon abandon abandon bail
bail bail oh yeah you better walk off
with your tail between your legs
I'm the king roost you over here baby
okay so I gotta get that one we go it's
still it still hits me every once in a
while that this is totally and
absolutely ridiculous and I get freaky
with the chickens at night oh yeah and
Bank my score and then I should have a
little baby following me right with my
baby well where's my baby oh I lost my
baby oh no oh I'm about to run out of
water
I actually I ran out of water and I
think there's something chasing me okay
there's something Oh God turtle the crap
out of me he's right there he's right
behind me I need to get some water but I
need to run away where is he huh he's
right there God isn't anyone guarding
these dang chickens
why did I even bother going into the
other area all the seeds were over here
well that ass not dad ass but I mean
that [ __ ] okay so I don't have time
to get more time these this is I'm a
good little chicken but I'm a good
little market chicken rooster plier
whatever you want to call me hi over
there you're guarding that time I know I
know I need to make another ticket baby
need to make another ticket baby oh yeah
I did it alright did it I made a baby
where's that little baby wait a baby go
no my baby my baby I begged my baby this
is so unbelievably ridiculous but so
actually awesome why is this awesome it
is this is probably one of the most fun
games I've ever played so what I should
have done is I should have ran around
and got time but I don't think I'm gonna
play this down I'm gonna play it over
time Who am I kidding
I'm going I'm going for it I'm going for
it let's do this baby
let's do damn wires dingdong dames okay
no time to mess around this time gun it
gun it gun it gun it
I don't know why this said delay on
starting it but I'm gonna get slurp go
give me dick thing give it give it give
it give it give it give it baby gonna
get a baby make me a baby baby let's get
oh God that was weird okay this is not
going well
oh here we go let's make a baby I got a
baby oh no time for that we got to go
but it's soup you know divert then must
get stuff good god okay I think I saw
more seeds over here mmm slurp slurp and
over here in the water little pond e
pond is that is that a seed yes indeed
no Fox is gonna get you not on my watch
hey look a watch is that my what that is
my watch oh yeah
oh yeah yeah yeah okay
oh that is a fox isn't it oh my watch is
over okay I got enough for another egg
I'm gonna make another baby cuz I'm just
so fear I'll and potent and alpha
rooster whatever you want to call that
[Laughter]
am I gonna have another little baby
[Music]
hello hi I'm gonna call you Billie and
I'm gonna call you smitty werben
jaegerman jensen oh there's ooh yeah
this yeah yeah man my food went down
making babies takes a lot of energy
apparently oh man and and I'm actually
gonna go out into the forest I don't
care if there's I seem to be able to
outrun the foxes at full gallop so I'm
gonna go over it this way yeah come on
long little babies got a time over here
[Music]
my babies I have no will to live you
bastard
you son of a [ __ ] I've actually upset
that you ate my babies you you're just
reading a log I'm gonna pick them press
out of your boy just stupid boy your
butt eat me did you see that it's but
eat meat okay believe it oh I got no
score cuz they never banked anything and
it ate my babies oh man that was
absolutely ridiculous but so much fun
for some reason I have no idea but
anyway that was awesome guys you gotta
check that one out if you gotta knock
his rip that's really really fun anyway
thank you all so much for watching click
the annotation for more videos that I've
done like I didn't I mentioned it I may
or managed it but I did dump me the
elephant that's another fun oculus rift
there are foreign oculus this game so if
you got why
you want me to play right in the
comments below or if you like to stuff
you know let me know so thank you all
someone for watching and as always we'll
see you in the next video
[Music]